this is the six of what i call my
chronicles of brooklyn new york
the republic of brooklyn new york
started way back with the first until
1986 she's going to have it
1989 do the right thing crookland
clockers
he got game and now
red hook summer
clark
is a wonderful actor he's one of the
great american actors working today
and most of you probably know clark from
the trilogy with david simon
don't
you know people talk about the wire
treme but it started with the corner
the corner
and then as detective lester freeman and
the wire and now he plays the mardi gras
indian in treme
and the staple david simon's work of
their ensemble pieces
which is great but for an actor
you know david is very democratic so
he's got to spread the stuff around
15 you know 15 people in the cast
so you get lost in the sauce
but i knew that he was such a great
actor
that given the role where he has to
carry a film
he would step up
and
it was very important to have an act of
his greatness because
it is a testament to his ability as an
actor and his humanity and his heart
that people come out of this theater
conflicted
i found out
got his number
called him up he was shooting treme
they're finishing up and it's not going
to come down there tomorrow i mean
i said when's your next day off said
tomorrow so i'm going to come down
tomorrow
and i'm going to
come to your door give you the script
two hours you got to read it because i
got to get back to new york
and he called me after an hour
and he said let's go
for the three
leads for the kids jules brown who plays
flick
tony lies safe he plays chaz
and
sincere peters who plays the young
blessed road during the molestation
scene they all
went to my old junior high school
there's a great drama teacher there his
name is mr edward robinson
and i knew once james i wrote the script
i knew i could sit in the back of mr
roberts class and find the three leads
i just sat in the back of the class four
or five times after the fourth time
they've been began to ask why are you
here
my next film is going to be we're
shooting film
but here's reality i financed this film
myself
i just bought i just
bought a sony f3 camera
and we had the shooted
in 18 days
as you know everybody knows here uh
budget determines how many days you
shoot
and we shot in a radius of like 10
blocks
yeah so we would have any you know lose
hours on company moves
you know this is a new day and if you
and we all know uh
you don't adapt
you perish
and i tell my students all the time that
any time there's any obstacle you can
not let the obstacle
stop you if
any institution whether it be hollywood
whoever it is the network's cable
they should not be the ones that say you
can't tell your story
one of my biggest influences was martin
scorsese and it's funny because
the first martin's going to say
something ever saw my mother took me to
see mean streets
my father hated movies
jazz position
so she i was my mother's movie date
and she would drag me to stuff i didn't
want to go i went kicking and screaming
but i always ended up saying thank you
and uh while i was in nyu he showed
after hours
scored stacy and after went up to him
and told him i was a film student he's
he's he's from nyu also right
and we've been friends ever since that
was even before she's gonna have it came
out
when i was in film school
kurosawa was doing publicity for ron
and this article really changed
everything for me for filmmaking i would
think it was a
second of my third year nyu grad film
school and journalists asked
kurosawa from paraphase he said you were
the greater one the greatest filmmakers
ever a massive filmmaker
is your film ron i think he might have
been 84 85 at the time
so don't shoot me if it's the wrong age
and the journalists asked kurosawa what
else do you have to learn
and kurosawa said there's a universe
of
knowledge of filmmakers you have to
learn
so when kurosawa said that and i'm a
second-year film student
that was like a bolt of lightning
so
everything i do
is about learning